coming soon on September 5th we need to
develop visions of how things could
change realistic and ambitious ones
because we're gonna need to change a lot
the future of Life Institute is
launching a new limited edition podcast
series about imagining alternative
Futures it's called imagine a world and
it's about hope I turn my building of
Technology makes me feel so isolated
well what if it didn't what if it made
me feel connected able to share my ideas
and be with like-minded people what if
that was the main experience that I was
having of it our host Guillaume reason
interviews the creators of eight diverse
and thought-provoking imagined Futures
that were received as part of the World
building contest fli ran last year so
one of the what if questions governing
our world was well what would activists
do if they were involved with AI what
could artists do what kinds of other
potentials could we see in actualize
over the course of Eight Episodes we'll
explore topics that range from the
promise of personalized medicine the
revolution that virtual Nations could
bring how trusted AI advisors could
reshape our economy and how animal
communication might make us rethink our
relationship to the natural world I
guess the hope is that people will think
more critically about everything about
the systems about the technology but
then also recognizing that you know
everyone needs to be a part of this and
crucially we also hear ideas for how to
overcome today's challenges you know so
many of the world's problems today seem
to be coordination problems like I'm
kind of coming out from a position of
Doubt like I have ideas that I'm excited
about like prediction markets and
Affinity cities but these things haven't
been tried and there's a lot of Kinks
that need to be worked out imagine a
world will be released on September 5th
on Apple music Spotify and YouTube if
you're subscribed to the main fli
podcast with Gus you'll be the first to
hear the new series when it comes out
for more information or to sign up to
our mailing list visit worldbuild Dot AI